PROFESSOR: Here
is your potential.
It's going to be a smooth,
nice potential like that.
V of x.
x, x.
And now, suppose you
don't know anything
about the energy eigenstates.
Now, this potential will
be assumed to be symmetric.
So here is one thing you can do.
You can exploit some things that
you know about this potential.
And here's the wave
function that we're
going to try to plot.
And we could say the following.
Let's see.
Whatever energy are
here, for bound states,
I'm going to eventually be
in the forbidden region.
So far on the right here, I
will be in the forbidden region.
And I must meet
the wave function
that looks like the forbidden
region wave function.
And the only possibility
is something like that.
You could say it's
the [INAUDIBLE] of 1,
but actually, if it's
a [INAUDIBLE] then
I could multiply by minus 1 and
use this one conventionally.
That wave function
is always going
to be like that over there.
On the other hand,
very important-- the
on the very left, how will
the wave function look?
Well it also has to decay,
so it can decay like that,
or it might be
decaying like this.
And in fact, you don't
know until you figure out
what's happening in the middle.
It may be decaying
like this or like that.
I fix the sign here,
so whatever this
does it should either end up
like that or end up like that.
So these are the guidelines
that you have to solve this.
Should begin like
that, and we'll see.
And it should be either
symmetric or anti-symmetric.
This would be the
case anti-symmetric,
this would be the
case symmetric.
OK.
So let's draw one, two,
three, four lines there.
One, two, three, and four.
And I don't know where
the energies lie.
I don't know what is
the ground state energy.
And I want to give you
an insight into how
you can figure out why you
get this energy one decision
when this happens.
So let's plot the wave
function for the first case.
I don't know if I have a
label, but let's assume
this is E0, E1, E2, E3.
Three energies [INAUDIBLE],
and here's the one for e0.
OK.
So I begin here,
that's how it goes.
And then I go through
my Schrodinger equation,
integrate it.
You see?
Numerical, you can always
integrate the Schrodinger
equation.
And this should be always
in this region, let me--
like this.
And it's growing.
And, oops, there should
be turning points here.
There should be turning points--
suppose this is--
I'm not going to get this so
well, but it goes like this.
And now this should
be a turning point.
So I should change to the
other type of curvature,
curvature down.
But what probably will happen
with E0 is that it will switch
and it will go like and
start to curve, maybe.
Well, if it looks
like that, it must
match to the development of the
odd piece or the even piece.
Now, it's never going to
match with the odd one,
so it might be with the even.
And yes, it would match
turning point here,
but look what has happened here.
You got the corner there.
You know, this was
turning slowly,
and this is starting
to turn slowly,
but here there is
a discontinuity
in the derivative.
So this is not the solution.
You try, but you fail.
But that's-- right.
Not every energy
gives a solution.
So they should have
matched continuously
and derivative
continuously at that point,
but it didn't have
enough time to do that.
On the other hand, if we
try the next one, maybe.
The turning points will be here.
Let's see what happens.
Well, now the forbidden
energies are over here,
and now you have a
turning point here that--
in here, the
curvature is negative,
the second
derivative's curvature.
And it's larger
than it was here.
Here it was small,
here it's larger.
So it's going to curve faster.
Maybe if you get
the E1 right, it
will curve enough so this
flat here, in which case
the other side will match nicely
and you've got the solution.
So you probably have
to go little by little
until this becomes
flattened and, boom,
you've got the solution.
Energy eigenstate.
Let's go a little further.
This graph continues there.
Now I want to go to E2.
How am I going to do that?
I'm going to do it this way.
So this was here,
this was there.
There is the vertical line here.
And for E2, the turning
points are even further out.
And here is the wave function.
And let's look at this
thing that I have.
Now, the turning point
in this one corresponds
to the E2 turning point.
This is E1.
And now this will go
in here, we'll turn,
and we will go curve and
maybe do something like that.
Because it's curving more
and more, and faster.
So by the time you
reach here, this
is no good, because this
one will be symmetric.
You know, you would have
an anti-symmetric one
that is no use.
But now you don't have
a solution, again.
So as you increase the energy,
this is starting to do this,
and that is not quite so good.
And then when you go to E3, you
have a turning point over here.
So maybe in this case
it will go up here
and it will start turning, and
it will turn enough to just--
this dip go to the origin.
OK.
You're saying no good either,
because this is terrible, this
continuous.
But, ah, you were supposed to
draw the other one as well.
The old one is actually
perfect for it.
So this is dash,
it doesn't exist,
and this one matches here.
So by the time the dip--
this is not a solution, but
the dip goes down and down,
and eventually goes to zero,
it matches with this one.
That's why I said sometimes you
don't know whether this matches
with the one that
comes from here
or the one that comes
from the bottom.
So there you go.
This is an energy
eigenstate again.
It's odd and it has one node.
And that gives you
the intuition how,
as you sort of come from the
end and you reach the middle,
you sometimes match things
or sometimes don't match.
And explains why you
get energy quantization.
The other way in which you're
going to gain intuition
is with the so-called
shooting method,
which is the last thing I
want to discuss for a minute.
So the shooting method
in differential equations
is quite nice.
Shooting method.
Suppose you have a potential
that this symmetric may
be something like this--
it doesn't look very symmetric.
It looks a little better now.
And you want to find
energy eigenstates.
You do the following.
You say, well, the normalization
of the energy eigenstates
is not so important.
Let's look for even states.
Now, you can look for
even or odd states
if the potential is symmetric.
Sometimes the potential will
have a wall, in which case
you have to require a
symmetric potential.
It's easy to solve, as well.
But let's consider the case
when the potential is symmetric
and you look for even states.
So what you do is just,
say, you pick an energy.
Pick some energy E0.
And then you put some
boundary condition.
You say that the wave
function at x equals 0 is 1.
And then you say that the
derivative of the wave function
at x equals zero is how much?
Any suggestion?
How much should it be?
You see, you have a second
order differential equation.
The second psi is equal to E
minus V. That's the Schrodinger
equation.
You need-- the boundary
conditions are the value of psi
and the derivative at one
point, and then the computer
will integrate for you.
Mathematica will do it.
But you have to give
me the derivative, so
what should I put?
A number there, 1, 2, 3?
Is that an unknown?
What should I pick?
We must put in the 0, because
if you had a wave function whose
derivative is not 0, and
it's an even wave function,
it would look like this.
And there would be a
discontinuity in psi prime--
discontinuous.
And that's not possible
unless you have a hard wall
or you have a delta function.
So you must put this.
And then you
integrate numerically.
Numerically.
And what will happen?
Well, if you
integrate numerically,
the computer is just going to
integrate and see no problem.
Basically, it's just
going to do the interview.
Ask the computer to calculate
the wave function out
to x equal 5, it
will calculate it.
So the problem is that--
you can see visually,
if you pick some energy,
the wave function will
do like something,
and then will start blowing up.
And then you say,
oh, that energy
is no good because the wave
function won't be normalizable.
And then you go
back to the computer
and change the
energy a little bit,
and then you will
find, well, maybe this.
Now it blows up in
the other direction.
No good either.
But in some energy in
between, as you change,
there must be one
in which it does
the right thing, which is BK.
Somewhere in between.
And numerically, you change
the value of the energy,
you go-- in the shooting
method, when you shoot
it either goes up or down.
And you start working
within those two numbers
to restrict it
until you get here.
If you have a solution
with five-digit accuracy,
it will do this, this,
this, and then blow up.
If you have a solution
with 10 digits after it,
it will do this and go up
to here and blow up again.
You need 500-digits
accuracy to get that wall.
But it's a fun thing that you
can do numerically and play
with it.
You can calculate five digits
accuracy, ten digits accuracy
within a matter of minutes.
It's very practical,
and it's very nice,
but one thing you have to
do is clean up your equation
before you start.
You cannot have an equation in
Mathematica with h-bar and m
and all that.
So you have to clean up the
units, is the first step,
and write it as an equation
question without units.
Your And this plots very
nicely in Mathematica,
and you will have
lots of practice.